>> Today's talk with
me by Professor Anish
Arora. Thank you.
I'll try to give
an introduction for
Professor Anish Arora.
I know him through Manik.
I guess, as we saw
yesterday in past lessons
in the next work in
wireless sensing,
I think he's worked
on various networks,
and sensing networks in the past.
Right? Past 20 years.
Professor Anish has been
using Microsoft Research
for the last 20 years, again.
From what I gathered,
they've spent 10 years
on building their
hardware ecosystem,
and datasets around what
he'll be talking today.
So, I hope we can learn
from their expperience.
>> Thank you. Thank you
for the invitation.
It's great to be
at Microsoft with
all these wonderful
minds and to meet
all friends and run into lots
of new folks and great new ideas.
By the way, 20 years ago,
we started working on
device networks at Microsoft.
So, Bill Gates had
his own home network,
and different groups in
Microsoft were coming up
with their own version.
So, when research,
Human Vangh and I,
were working on device networks.
Somehow that attracted
DARPA's attention,
which got me to working in
wireless sensor networks.
Before that, I did distributed
computing in theory.
So, building things
is something I
credit Microsoft to
getting me into.
So, yesterday, we spoke about
the role of Mote-Scale computing,
and how it leverages
machine learning,
and it's poised to
leverage deep learning.
So, today, I really want
to focus on deep learning.
I'll just pick up on
that topic of issues we
run into using shallow
machine learning at Mote-Scale.
These issues I'll
phrase in terms of
this concept of limited signals,
which is a vague concept.
But, I'll try to
give you different
conceptions of limited signal,
and how it impacts
the design in question.
Yeah? So, just as a recap.
Mote-Scale is
battery-powered stuff.
You've got radios, your wireless.
The consumption of
power is limited.
It's typically well
below 100 milliwatts.
You could use energy harvesting.
You have one or more sensors.
You have one or more processors.
So, just to illustrate the
details of one type of Mote,
here is something that
we have been using.
For a decade or so,
we use systems like
these small 8-bit Motes
from say TI,
and used an operating system
called TinyOS,
which was a remarkable concept
for being a resource constraint.
It turned out TinyOS,
even though we trained
thousands of students,
didn't transition very well.
Quite simply because it
was not easy to program.
So, here you have the challenge
of addressing low-power,
and this low-power can exploit
all these rich low-power modes.
For example, this
cortex M3 Mote that
we called the.NOW Mote,
has really nice low-power states.
It's really a software
design challenge
to be able to exercise those
low-power states correctly.
So, to address
this issue that it was
hard to get people to
change how they program,
we had to revert to
a standard programming language.
We said, we would work in C#.
Yeah. So, we actually took
a system which was built
at Microsoft Research
about 20 years ago,
it's called the.NET
Micro Framework,
and we took the.NET Micro
Framework, and we stripped it.
We made it near real time,
improved its jitter,
and added wireless
capabilities to it.
So, what we've ended up with
is a runtime that
we call the eMote,
where you can run at
the moment interpreted,
and not just in time
compiled C# programs,
and we get pretty decent jitter.
We can program application
specific networks.
The way we do this is by
abstracting the radio link
as a virtual link.
These could be multiple radios,
so all links are offered to
the network pattern
as a virtual link.
So, you can custom design
your network at
an abstract level.
With this framework
for virtualization,
and these very general
network patterns,
we can come up with a rich class
of wireless sensor networks.
The point I wanted to make was
that a Mote is
largely software designed.
In fact, even the sensors
are becoming largely
software designed,
and of course programming
the application at
this high level is a convenience
that we would like
to build on. Yes.
>> What do you mean by sensors
are software designed?
>> Okay. So, as
you noticed I showed you
yesterday the radar.
The radar is actually just
giving a simple complex value.
But, this complex
value represents
the cumulative returns
in some region.
Now, how do I
control that region?
Should I actually introduce
those knobs in hardware,
and exercise some kind
of hardware tuning,
or I can program
those knobs in software?
So, this particular
radar has an FPGA,
and most of the sensor control
is in the software itself.
Increasingly, you
will find that that's
the right pattern for
leveraging the sensors.
Right? This is somewhat
counter-intuitive,
but we keep thinking of
digital mems as
encoding in hardware,
more and more
complex computation.
But, in fact, sometimes
just beginning
with a much lower power
analog mems,
and doing the rest in software
is not only more flexible,
but also lower power.
So, software defined sensing is
the thing that we can build on,
although it continues to
grow at the Mote scale.
It isn't the dominant pattern,
but what we're finding is it's
a very useful pattern,
at Mote scale.
Of course, all the features
that you generate,
as all of us are doing,
is done in software.
Right? So, we are not
assuming that we're
limiting ourselves to
some features, which are,
for example, features
like extracting
certain filters which are
defined in the hardware itself.
We are defining our own features.
So, by limited signal,
what I mean is various things.
So, one of the forms
of limited signal
is I've got a signal
which is rather weak.
So, we're looking at targets
which may not be
conceptually large.
We're in this low-power regime
where this target compared
to the whole scene
is rather small.
So, the signal in terms of
power itself can be quite small.
Now, of course, if you've
got an active sensor,
and the active sensor
is battery powered,
it's radiating at very low power.
For example, in
the case of the radar,
we are radiating energy,
and the reflections
are coming back in
a width of fourth power
of reduction.
So, you've got signal which is
quite low in the
presence of noise and
the key design challenges to
find how you can represent
that signal in a way
that you get a good quality of
SNR to still be able to
do your computing tasks.
Now, in addition to
the noise being large,
the background
environment presents
a lot of diversity and
magnitude of return.
We can think of that as clutter.
We can place our sensors in
regimes where in
addition to the target,
there's a large amount
of clutter,
which is contributing to
essentially a form of noise,
which we have to reject. Now,
sometimes, one can make
a distinction between
the objects in the scene as being
targets of interest and
targets not of interests.
So, there might be a distinction
between clutter
and targets not of
interests and
these targets not of
interest also have
to be rejected.
Yeah. So, that also
constraints your signal.
Now, if you get into
sort of a more interesting
set of concerns,
this is when sensors can
interfere with each other.
So, the returns of an object
can essentially be interfering.
Now, that can happen
in multiple ways,
which I'll try and
outline in the talk.
But we'll have to think about how
interference affects your design.
Now, in certain cases,
you might think about
this interference as being
somewhat constructively
or adversarially done.
Somewhat deliberately done.
So, I'll define
this concept called
obfuscation and now the question
becomes, how do you deal with?
How do you leverage obfuscation?
Is it a good thing
or a bad thing?
Of course depends on
your application and what
can you do about that.
A form of obfuscation can
simply be spoofing targets,
by constructively
creating fake targets on
the scene rather than
just jamming the sensor.
So, that's a very rough
definition of the kinds
of challenges we run
into in applications,
and I wanted to spell out
how we've thought about it.
Really much of our work
is driven by the application
and methods are
quite basic in some cases and
there's a lot of room for
growing this that could
lead to an interesting
conversation.
So, what applications
is sort of incorrect,
I'll just focus on one
application given the time today.
So, the story about
why we've gotten to
forest protection is
really quite basic.
We've in the last 40 years,
the wildlife of the world
has gone down by 70 percent.
One way of reacting,
and this says it's not just sort
of a simple ecological concern,
it is also an economic concern.
There are many dimensions
to this concern about how
human development is being
affected by wildlife reduction,
and one way of reacting to
that problem is to deal
with large mammals.
Large mammals at the top of
the animal species hierarchy have
this not only this attention
that gets to people,
but in fact if you're able
to tame the damage to them,
its contribution to the rest
of the chain is
quite significant.
So, we ran into problems
like in India in 2009,
the tiger went extinct
in certain parks.
Took them a few years to
discover it was extinct.
They were looking at pockmarks
and they thought it was there,
but in fact they
were over-counting
the same mark as being
multiple tigers.
So, they didn't realize
the decline and they
didn't come up as
being ready for it.
So, they had to do things
like transplanting tigers.
So, around 2011, we started
this project with
a number of partners.
Where I was looking at
radar sensor networks,
my colleagues at
ISC we're looking
at PIR sensor networks.
My colleagues at Tripolitania
Lehenga we're looking at
a very cool fiber-optic
based classification
of animal targets.
Really really good topic,
but that's for another day.
So, the way this is a baby
formulation of the problem.
So, you've got a reserve
or a national park,
and in this park what we
would like to do is to see
whether people or animals
are at points of interest.
So, there are crossing points
where either animals should
not be or people should
not be and at
these points of interest,
you want to detect the activity.
In particular this activity
has in the sense of
targets not of interests,
has got to reject some types
of activity while
focusing on other relevant
types of activity.
So, for example in
the particular, so,
we did one deployment in
the Panna National
Reserve which is
a tiger Reserve then we did
another deployment in 2016
in an unnamed park
in South Africa.
This was done with
the World Wildlife Fund,
and the idea was here
the poachers when they come in,
they come in with dogs,
and they come in small groups
of two or three people.
So, you had to discriminate
these poachers,
but when cattle
were going through
the scene or goats were
going through the scene,
you didn't have to
alarm the guides.
Now, it turns out there
is no to my knowledge,
a national park or
a forest which is
uniformly covered by
communications, like cellular.
It turns out you're lucky if at
the guard stations you got
cellular or some network access,
and so we leveraged that.
Let's assume the guard
station is connected,
we have these operational points,
we want to do
this discrimination at
the operational points,
reach the guard station,
from the guard station
reach the cloud.
From the cloud, contact
the management,
because guards have
to be kept honest,
and also if allowed contact
various social networks.
Because a good way of socializing
the response to crime
is to actually,
good way to deal with
crimes to actually
socialize the response to them,
depending on how progressive
park managements are.
Now, for this system to work,
of course it had to work
in this hostile terrain.
You've got a low power network
which has to cover large areas.
These parks tend to be
hundreds of square kilometers.
But now it's about 650.
This park we were in was
probably about
two-thirds of that.
Then you had to
make sure that this
was easy to operate
and to maintain.
That's a key requirement.
Because even though
you train the guards,
the guards themselves have
limited technical competence.
Cost is an important
constraint in the design,
because these parks are
very cash strapped.
To some extent the adversary
is very intelligent
and it's very organized and
it's very legally supported.
So, you have to be concerned
about this had been
somewhat stealthy,
accurate, robust, and reliable.
So, all these are
issues and that takes
us as a motivation into
the limited signal case.
So, here's how we
dealt with this.
We used this concept
of a virtual fence.
Although these parks
are very large,
often the crossings are
happening in
small linear sections.
So, for example, in
this park in South Africa,
there was a remote corner
of the park where you had
a river which was very easily
flooded at certain times
of the month,
and there were
certain flood points.
So, there were
many strips which were
roughly 100 to 150 meters long.
So, if you could cover
these 13 strips,
you had covered one major zone.
Sometimes you have
a bunch of watering holes
and poisoning is a form
of getting to the animal,
so you had to detect what was
going on at the watering hole.
Alternatively, a third
pattern was that,
there were these ingress routes
where people would
actually drive in.
Coming fast, shoot and head out.
Yeah. This is a form of
crime which is particularly
true in India.
Whereas, the poachers
in South Africa,
they were actually
coming on foot and
walking very fast for
significant distances. Yes?
>> How did you get to know this?
>> Say again.
>> All these things are deeply
well understood, right?
These patterns are well-known.
In fact, the organization
is such that,
sometimes the
villagers are helping
the poachers because of
complex social relationships.
You can harm me, I
will not tell on you.
But when you're coming,
I'll actually feed
you for the night, let
you sleep and go on.
These patterns are
well understood,
but it's distrust between
authorities and local people.
That's one major source
of contention here.
The other thing is,
I'm not suggesting technology
is the answer to
this big problem.
It's a very small element
at the bottom of
the response hierarchy,
but it's a necessary element,
and that's the part
that we're focused on.
So, here is just to get
you to visualize what's
happening in South Africa.
So, it's about, I would say
five or six kilometers
from this river area,
is a guard station.
The guard station is
on the top of a hill.
It has this tall chimney.
On a tall chimney, we've
got a base station going.
This base station has
got line-of-sight
visibility to a bunch
of abutting hills.
These hills could be two
kilometers, three kilometers,
four kilometers away, so we can
create single low-power
links to them.
These routers to which
the first DARPA links are
could be put on poles,
they could be put on trees.
And now at these tops
of these hills,
we somehow have to go
down into the valley,
so that we can communicate with
the sensors which are
placed along the river.
The sensors are, here scale
size is not an issue.
We didn't really have
to go much smaller.
In fact, perhaps in
our earlier deployments,
we even had this size.
So, you can mount these
on little branches,
on little trees, and you put
them at a certain height.
You don't want the radar
in this case to be
at ground level,
but here, we had
a solution which was roughly
on this form factor.
Now, a little bit of a background
around how radars work.
So essentially, this is
a micropower Doppler radar.
So it's not a continuous wave,
you're shouting out pulses.
Pulses are sent at
a high frequency.
You can send them a million,
or two, or three million
times a second.
That's the pulse
repetition frequency.
So this generated, this is
a very old concept
of radar which is called
homodyne invader.
That when these multiple pulses,
this is an example of
a single pulse is shouted,
it travels to the target,
the reflection comes back,
and the reflection is convolved
with a duplicate of
the transmitted pulse.
That convolution
contains the information
that you're looking for.
So, we are running at what might
be a few percent of duty cycle
of a continuous wave,
and you're shouting out
something that's very low power,
so the overall power consumption
is not too much.
That said, this is
the biggest consumer of
power in our system.
Over the years, we've had
many versions of the radar.
We started off with 30 milliwatt,
went to 40 milliwatt,
and finally have been
able to pull that
back to around 16 milliwatt.
And we think we have
designs which will
go down to a couple of milliwatt,
but that's going to
be real research.
So, you have
this big power consumer,
but still in
the low-power regime,
which we are going to analyze
our information from.
Here, I spoke to this
a little bit yesterday,
but what you have is
this complex return.
And this complex return,
as the target approaches
has this particular pattern
which grows stronger,
and the phase rotates,
and the rotation of the phase
gives you a sense of how
much distance is traveled.
Yeah. So, this by
itself is an interesting
feature to begin with.
So, if you look at the nature
of the clutter response,
the clutter response which has
all these bushes and trees around
the radar are actually
not producing much
change in phase.
This phase is self-canceling.
But if a human or
a target not of interest
goes through the scene,
that is a displacing object.
Something that's
not moving in situ,
and you can see that there is
a significant change in the
phase which we can track.
So, you've got a basis for
starting on
discriminating objects.
But, if you want to
get finer grain,
then you can look at
not just the amplitude
and the phas signatures,
you can look at
the time-frequency signatures.
So, here are signatures
of how a car,
which is a rigid object,
corresponds to a very narrow
band of excited frequencies.
But the human and a dog,
which is a soft target,
have this much richer
frequency spread.
And within this frequency spread,
although not very nicely
visible at this resolution,
are very interesting
micro Doppler buttons.
You can see not just the torso,
you can see the limbs.
You can actually discriminate
the arms and the legs.
And in fact, that becomes
a basis from discriminating from
the dog because the feet
typically are much more spindly,
and therefore you don't have
much return from the legs.
>> Is this a spectogram
of the face shift?
You look at the face shift with
time, but this is another one.
>> So, this is frequency.
What we're seeing is
the frequencies which
are excited over time, right?
>> This is the Doppler Shift.
>> This is the Doppler
shift, precisely.
Now, how do you classify?
I will not spend
much time on this.
You track the displacement,
and you can reject
things which are
moving in situ based on
that previously explained idea of
how the displacement on graphs,
whereas in situ movements do
not traverse much distance.
And then, you run
this support vector machine
which leverages a bunch
of features that
we have designed.
It took a while to layout
something like 80 features.
Here is an example of
a feature which says that,
what is the area of
excitation above a certain
threshold in the spectrogram?
So for a dog, that anomaly area
is much smaller than
for a human target,
and we hope this has
an interesting feature.
We have no idea whether to work.
We'd throw data at it,
and we look at the relevance
of these features.
How much information
gain they have,
and we tried to select features.
Then, we of course
implement this,
and details of that are not
relevant at the moment.
Any questions before
I really begin?
>> [inaudible] do we
calibrate the [inaudible].
>> So, this is the story
I would like to
tell in the next few slides.
The aspiration is, I will collect
data from multiple clutters,
multiple backgrounds,
on multiple targets, on
multiple instances of radar
of different generations,
and come up with a classifier
that works for all.
That's the aspiration.
And the story I'd like to tell as
well which parts we succeeded on,
which bytes are still moving.
But, the brief answer is
for the longest time,
we've stuck with one classifier
for all environments.
That's the thing we're
working towards.
Okay. So, let's begin by saying,
"Well, clutters are
very different."
So, here is the response
in terms of amplitude.
Sorry, this is hard to read.
Amplitude of grass,
amplitude in a more
idealized setting,
where one would imagine
there are no reflectors
like just tarmac.
This is an airport where we
do experiments for DARPA.
Here is the change
in phase over time,
that access is called
rotations per second.
So, the unwrapped number of
rotations per second gives
you a sense of how
phase is changing.
As you can see, these are
significantly different in
both the amplitude
and the phase domain.
I don't know if it's absolutely
visible, but they are.
Yeah. So, now the target returns
will be superposed on
these variable clutter returns.
And the thinking is,
it's possible if you've collected
enough diverse environments to
estimate a worst case
background clutter,
and to choose a
displacement threshold
for targets in
these background clutters,
which will lead to a constant
number of false alarms,
so the false alarm
rate will be constant.
So, we want to allow
something like one a
month or one a year,
and that at this point of
description is feasible.
So, I'll give a chart
to that momentarily.
That's a simple explanation.
The more interesting
explanation is,
you would have thought
that grass is,
there's more clutter in
grass than in
the idealized concrete.
So you should have had
higher noise in the grass case.
Turns out it's the opposite.
A lot of that has to do with
the implementation of the radar,
the particular choice of
the components and
how the intermodes,
et cetera, get affected
by these targets.
In fact, concrete is
an environment in which
the phase noise drifts.
Whereas, when there
is more clutter,
the phase noise actually
tends to become quiescent,
counter-intuitive, but
again something unanticipated.
Now, if we just step back from
clutter and just look at
the underlying board noise.
The underlying
board noise itself,
has varied significantly
across various generations.
This is a very recent radar,
the 16 milliwatt radar
I was referring to,
where the median of
the amplitude in this,
is just plain simple noise,
is this number 10.
Whereas, the radar that
we put in South Africa,
the median of that is says
substantially higher at 72.4.
Yeah. And conversely, when
you look at the rotations,
you'll see that
the noise rotations
are higher for
this radar as well.
For different radars,
we have to be
able to tolerate
this underlying noise.
The way we do that is by
doing an online estimation
of the background noise.
You maintain this estimate of
the background amplitude
and what you say is,
"I'm going to choose some number
that I have learned,
some estimate,
some functional estimate of
the background noise which if
it shows up in the return,
I will treat that as noise and I
will reject that sample."
I'm actually going
to be throwing away
samples which corresponds to what
I am hypothesizing
is a noise return.
Now, the net effect
of that is that of
course you're actually throwing
away some signal returns.
You've got soft targets.
The soft target
amplitudes will vary.
Some of those soft target
returns we will throw away.
We are going to underestimate
our displacement,
and so the learning of
the displacement threshold now
gets coupled with the sample
rejection threshold.
Around 2010, what we found
was that in many environments if,
this is like an empty field.
There's a parking garage.
There are lots of trees,
grasses, different places,
and we found that
a single threshold
could give you
this constant false alarm.
But as we went to generations
of the radar where
the noise grew a lot,
that gave us a
displacement threshold
where we started to
have false negatives.
We had to introduce this concept
of background rejection and
after we do background
rejection in all
of the environments
we've collected data on,
that technique will work.
We've come up with
this online algorithm
for estimating the noise
and having trained for
various levels of noise,
for various levels of rejection,
what the threshold
is going to be.
>> What's applied there?
>> Here, what we have is
a log scale which says
the probability of
the false alarm as a function
of the distance
that is traversed.
Yeah. What this is saying is,
if you look at a case
where you have trees,
the probability of the
false alarm drops more quickly.
In order to reject tree movement,
a threshold of 0.17 meters
would have been sufficient to
give you a probability
of false alarm which
was significantly less than
one false alarm a week,
or one false alarm a month.
Yeah. But you'd have to
use a larger threshold to
reject whatever
this parking garage one is.
As the noise increased for us,
this threshold that we had to
reject became something
like 0.65 meters,
and that was competing with what
actual displacements
on targets were.
So we would have gotten
false negatives.
Yeah. In order to reign
in the false negative,
we introduced the background
rejection and then
chose this universal
threshold backed here.
What we are saying is
something like 0.4
meters is sufficient to
reject clutter in
these different environments.
>> [inaudible].
>> Yes.
This is the phase shift.
>> [inaudible].
>> Yeah, in rotations yes, yes.
In a window. Exactly, precisely.
Yeah. So the window of
course is dictated by
the windows that we use
for discriminating
displacement, right?
There are also, we've got
to build in the fact that
our targets are not moving
continuously, they pause.
Yeah. They will
change orientation,
so we have to introduce
some techniques
for handling those
cases in those Windows.
In fact, I suspect those ideas
may be relevant for you.
We can take that offline.
>> Yes.
>> [inaudible] also.
>> Yes. This data set
includes high wind,
presence of rain, moving
water nearby in
the scene et cetera.
This is painful, right? We have
to collect all these data.
Now, to get to Shusa's question.
The question is how do you
design a classifier which
works in a new environment
which you haven't
encountered before?
The very simple observation
is trying not to
train from data collected
in similar environments.
There is a real gap between
the performance that
you expect to get,
between a system which
has been trained for
different environments
versus a system
which has been trained
in similar environments.
We started doing designs
where we are looking at
what the cross-environmental
information gain features.
That leads to
this very simple idea
but maybe I'll spell it out.
Here is a feature
which is not robust.
If you look at frequency noise
and you look at the volume of
frequency of the energy
in this spectral domain
above a certain threshold,
that can change
quite substantially.
So it's not a robust feature.
But, if you just project
that spectral power of
activation above a threshold into
the area or the shape
of that activation,
then that seems to
be much more robust.
We'd like to find in
our feature selection,
not just features which
have high information gain,
but which are likely to show
very low variance across
different environments.
That led to this work where we
came up with techniques for
starting off with things like
MRMR information gain
or information gain,
but then actually pruning
out those features by adding
this dispersion
component which we
called the Mean
Absolute Deviation.
We're trying to basically
minimize this variance and
that's modeled by trying
this hyperparameter
which takes into account
the relative importance of
the information gain
and the variability.
Roughly speaking,
the very simple idea
is choose those
features which are
going to have low variance across
environments while not
losing information too much.
That's the answer
to your question.
Now, we run into cases
which are more interesting.
Okay. The first case
is a case where,
assume that the pulses generated
by a radar are periodic.
Assume accidentally
the pulses generated by
two radar are perfectly aligned.
Now the return of a target from
radar one might show up in
the reference pulses which
are convolved for radar two.
Yeah. Now targets which are
potentially not even in
the scene of radar one,
sorry, not in the scene
of radar two are showing
up because radar one
is exciting them.
Yeah. That's a problem that
shouldn't be allowed, right?
Normally, we don't really place
radars very close to each other.
If I'm counting the number
of people in this room,
one radar should be sufficient,
but you know if there's
a neighboring room
which has its own radar
the question is,
am I seeing the targets
there in my return here?
The way you typically handle
this is by desynchronizing
the pulses,
and that's where software
control becomes helpful.
Yeah. How much randomness
you want to create,
what patterns you want to create
become something
that you program.
Now, another topic is,
it's one thing to
say a single target
displaced for the scene
and the phase
unwrapped nicely but what
happens if multiple targets
are in the scene?
The simple cases is
when one target is
somehow dominant,
it's close to you.
Essentially, what you are
tracking is that one target.
But if there are cases
where you want to
count and the other target is
behind the dominant target,
how do you discover that?
So, we did some work on
counting classifiers,
actually regression
functions for counting.
Well, the very, very high level
summary is, first of all,
the longer you observe,
the more likely
the obfuscated targets
will reveal themselves.
Counter-intuitive, but it took
us a little while
to discover that.
The second one was that there are
certain features where you can
look at shadows of objects,
hidden imprints of objects.
So, we discovered
the need for looking in
the spectrogram for gradients.
So, you had this strong return,
this area of excitation.
But you also saw that
there was a smooth,
not too sharp
gradient besides it,
which was indicative
of some other
objects which were there.
So, you started using
those gradient features to
build your estimates of
the number of people.
So, any questions on that idea?
Really, these are
separate pieces of work,
and I'm not explaining
them at much length.
>> Sir.
>> Yes.
>> So, in the case
of cross-target,
do you want to develop
on the target or you just want
to set above the one target?
>> Yes. It depends
on your application.
So, in the sense that
I was describing
for this room that's really about
counting the utilization
of the room.
So, we can do various things.
We could decide how much air
to pump through a room
based on its utilization.
That's an energy saving. So, yes.
Sometimes, you really do want to
count the number of targets.
Another example is
this bike pedestrian network
that we are deploying,
where we want multiple points
of utilization across
a Trail Network.
Currently, that's not
very well handled.
What you have is
data from phones,
where people who are going
through those trails
are self-reporting.
But you don't know what fraction
of the population is
doing that very well to
build your estimates.
The other technologies
are quite manual.
So, the planning in a city
like Columbus is largely
based on trying out
some technologies,
but actually depending
on human counts than
twice a year to estimate
which trails are being used,
which ones to fix etcetera.
So, we'd like to actually do low
cost counting at multiple points
in the Trail Network.
Here, this problem of
obfuscation is basic for us.
Now, there is a different form of
obfuscation which is
somewhat privacy-centric.
So here, I'll be describing
radar-like classification,
but I'll be doing it in
the traditional comms domain.
So, in the recent several years,
there's been a bunch
of work where
people have looked at
wireless signals and you look
at the side channel of the
wireless signal in some sense
by extracting the
low-frequency components
of the signal out of it,
by integrating
a number of samples.
So, just like we were using
a basis for recognizing,
that there was a target
and the scene by a radar,
you can look at
the WiFi columns which are
reflecting off this target
to discriminate,
is there a person in this room
or how many people are
there in this room?
Now, supposing I want to
hide the fact that somebody
outside can observe
outside my house,
can observe whether
somebody's at home or not.
How would I do that? So, that's
this concept which
I call obfuscation.
So, the idea is
something like this.
This is the signal
being transmitted.
being received either
at the Wi-Fi receiver
or at your sensor.
That depends, that has
these three degrees of freedom.
So, the target influences
the amplitude,
it influences the Doppler shift,
and it influences
the propagation delay.
So, I have these three
degrees of freedom,
and I don't know what sensor
this is going to be used,
but the sensor is
somehow going to use
some combination of information
in these three degrees
of freedom.
Okay. So, what I would
like to do is to somehow
obscure the information in
these degrees as follows.
So, what I'm going to do is to
introduce yet another node
that I call an obfuscator,
which is going to transmit
copies of the incoming signal.
So, this signal is being sent
in parallel to
the transmission signal.
So, it all has to be
constructive in some sense.
So, we are using for
this obfuscated and
implementation which is
based on Full Duplex radios.
So, in this copy that
we are going to relay,
we are going to perturb in
these three dimensions.
We're going to perturb
the by adding
an amplitude component,
we are going to perturb by adding
a potentially different
Doppler component
and a different phase component.
So, the net result is
that instantaneously,
we can distort the amplitude
and the phase.
But it turns out that
in the frequency,
that is still discriminable.
In order to compensate for that,
the rate at which your distort
becomes relevant.
So, as long as you are
distorting at a rate,
which is faster than what
sensor was trying to use,
then you should be sufficient.
There are some very
interesting details about
how the Full Duplex deals
with self-cancellation,
which I'm not going
to talk about.
But the interesting
thing is this,
an obfuscator can itself
prevent a sensor from working,
while itself, being
able to sense.
So, we can create
legitimate sensors while
simultaneously obfuscating
illegitimate sensors,
without by the way
affecting communication,
and that's a whole other story.
The communication rate in
fact doesn't go down it
goes up because we are
in fact relaying. Yes?
>> So can [inaudible] also use
simulitaneous obfuscating?
>> Yes of course. Yes of course.
Yeah. So, this is always
a cat and mouse game.
This research itself
is pure cat and mouse,
because I'm talking
about a single sensor,
a single antenna sensor.
If you got a distributed
array of observers,
then this technique will
say is not sufficient,
we have to move to
the next level in
that game of obfuscation.
So, here is sort of showing how-
as you introduce
distortions in copies,
what happens to the granularity
of the spectrograms as
the Doppler shift changes?
So, this higher rate of change
will give you a result
something like this.
Let's assume this is
the pattern that the
sensor was looking for.
After obfuscation,
you've essentially
removed the components
in every part of this,
so that pattern should no
longer be discoverable.
So, we gave implementations
PhyCloak and we showed how they
performed in at least
in the lab setting.
So, an interesting comment there
is much of the
technology, actually,
it's harder to make it robust
across different
environments for sensing,
but it's easier to obfuscate it.
That problem is easier.
Because all I'm doing is
I'm being destructive,
in the sensing domain not
the communication domain.
>> So, it means a [inaudible]
>> Yes.
This is all RF, right?
Yeah. In the radar,
you can actually do
something similar which is,
you can inject signatures.
So, if I know what
signature is to be
expected by your sensor,
I can pretend that there is
somebody in the room
by spoofing that.
My obfuscator can now
become a spoofer.
This is an example of a
measured spoofing to show how
you could emulate a particular
gesture like a pull.
So, the last topic I'd like to
focus on in terms of
limited signal is,
how do we deal with
the lack of data?
This is a problem we all face.
We go around buildings
in different ways and
collect information,
malls, forests, et cetera.
But there's a lot of
problems in this process.
Most importantly,
it's inefficient.
So, the cost of
this process is quite high.
So, in Chandigarh,
we collected data on
tigers and bears and elephants.
This may be [inaudible] ,
and we didn't get
fantastic data at all.
Tigers are very lazy
in the afternoon.
You don't want to collect
data on tigers in zoos.
So really, for building a tiger
versus human classifier,
I need data from elsewhere.
The impact of not having
data is quite simple.
Here for example,
you remember the phase chart I
showed you for
a human and a ball?
Here is the time-frequency
component for a large ball,
which is seen close to the radar
versus a human that's quite
far away from the radar.
You know from
a pattern perspective,
they look quite similar.
So, If I didn't have
sufficient data on weak humans,
this classifier would
likely had made a mistake.
Conversely, what we
find is that sometimes,
a single parameter for
our features is not enough.
You need multiple parameters
for your feature to
actually capture
the variability of targets.
So, to be able to capture
both the strong ball end
the week ball,
I might need multiple
parameter instances.
If I don't have
a rich enough data set,
I don't capture that fact.
Now, the problem
is almost wicked,
because your targets are
quite variable in size.
They actually work
quite differently,
men and women and children
walk differently.
Their speeds tend to
be quite variable,
their trajectories
are quite unknown.
They could be stopping, turning.
Dogs like to just go
around in circles,
and that's having a good time,
and their activities
while they're
doing this can be
changing quite a bit.
So, you need that variability
built in into your data collect.
Now, what sort of worse is,
the problem is almost inverted
because we've collected data
from radars which were placed
as I was telling you
at about three feet.
But what if a radar is
placed at eight feet?
In the vertical dimension,
it's a 30 degree angle.
So, the response that
you would get would
be very elevation dependent.
The orientation of
the radar matters just as well,
because it aspires to be
an omnidirectional sensor
but it is not exactly one.
It has got strong frontal lobes,
somewhat strong back lobes
and weaker side lobes.
So, the gain in different
directions is different.
As I told you,
the noise characteristics
can be different,
and across builds,
the wavelength can be different.
>> Are you using
an omnidirection item?
>> Why?
>> Are you using
an omnidirection?
>> Yes. Yes. It aspires
to be an omnidirection
but has artifacts in it.
So, even the central,
front lobe is somewhat
left-leaning.
It has to do with sort of
board capacitance effects
and all of that.
How well impedance
matching is done?
So, what we would
really like to do is to
augment our data synthetically.
I'd like to describe
our evolution and
augmenting data starting from
something trivial to
something more interesting.
So, here's a trivial idea
to get the stage set.
So, the radar is not
exactly omnidirectional.
So, you've got different gains.
So, if I have a radar file of
a target going on a radio,
where I know how
much its gain is larger
than another radio,
so this is controlled datas,
where a human is walking
along a certain radio.
If I vary the gain,
I can produce the same behavior
on a different orientation.
Sort of a trivial idea.
A slightly more
interesting is that,
if I focus on
the target who's walking
with a uniform speed,
big if, then I can come
up with a data set,
which works at
a different speed by
actually up-sampling
or down-sampling.
That turns out to
be conservative.
This one, as we test in training,
it's slightly less useful
than the previous one.
>> [inaudible] take the
signature, the radial signature
[inaudible] certain radius-
>> Yes.
>> And use this model
to imagine what it would look
like if someone walked
and then get sampling.
>> Precisely. Yes.
>> [inaudible] scratch.
>> No. No, no. So, we're
starting off with a data set,
some of which is controlled
and well-labeled,
and we're using that data
through these primitive models,
and they are primitive, trust me,
to generate other data.
If you generalize
this idea and you've
got walks in different
directions, some along radials,
some along orthogonals,
different radials,
you can synthesize pieces
and come up with
arbitrary trajectories.
So, you can come up
with a richer data set,
which is what this last one
was trying to spell out.
In the interest of time,
I won't spell it out, it's
really very simple physics.
Actually, the stuff
is not great at all.
Because a lot of our features
are looking for micro-Doppler.
I modeled house how
the gross body speed would
show up in this other walk,
but what about the micro-Doppler?
What have I done to it?
I may have actually distorted
it in a way that was
counterproductive.
So, what this has led us to,
is to rethinking how we
generate our synthetic data.
So, what we're doing
now is to say,
we need a source where we have
well-labeled data
from a co-sensor.
In this case, what
we are doing is we
have video which is giving
us these temporal sequences
of labeled information.
Now, then what we
would like to do from
this co-sensor we would
like to extract from
that the positions,
the orientations, the sizes
of the various components.
Then from that, we should be able
to generate via radar
simulation models traces.
So, to keep this somewhat
basic to begin with,
we start off with video,
from that video we
extract position,
orientation other information
and then we feed that into.
Knowing all the components of
the foreground and
perhaps some components
of the background,
we can superpose
all those returns
and come up with
the Radar return,
doing something like that and in
a radar simulation
toolbox, MATLAB.
Now, that idea itself can be
made a little bit richer,
by throwing in
various model parameters.
So here, even the video
has been captured at
a certain height,
at a certain orientation
often from a fixed camera,
but I want to try
various other orientations
and elevations.
So, now I can augment
the model that I'm
using for generating
the Radar data and
create many more
simulations out of that.
So, somewhat
pictorially speaking,
we had two approaches to
collecting video data.
One is to using
this Motion Capture.
Motion Capture you actually
get data for humans,
for dogs, for vehicles.
This is somewhat
publicly available,
sometimes you have to pay for it.
So, this is nicely labelled data,
where you've got
the body components
marked in it from which
skeleton data can be extracted.
Similarly, even with the Kinect
you can come up
with skeleton data,
now these joints can
be treated as the ellipsoids
and you can estimate
the limb ellipsoids for that,
and that can be used to
generate your radar simulation.
Conversely, you can decompose
the video into Polygons and
for each polygon element,
you can look at what
its response is going to be
and superpose those responses
in your radar simulation.
Now, having generated
all that data,
you can now try creating
other model instances
by throwing in
the parameter variations from
some set and come up
with a richer set.
So now, we're at the point
where we are looking at
the accuracy of
this richer generation,
it looks quite promising.
Coming into this workshop,
we had this debate about
whether we should use
synthetic data or not.
We're not using it now
but we think we should
be using it because it
is accurate enough.
Okay, so that was the story
I wanted to share
about limited signals and
roughly I'd like to
conclude by looking
ahead on where we
ought to be focusing.
So, one thing to ask
is we've had these,
somewhat primitive ways of
dealing with limited signal
for shallow learning,
but these issues are
going to be handled,
must be handled in
the deep learning work.
So, how does
deep learning provide us
a good basis for handling
limited signal issues?
A bunch of questions
there I think
which should be
interesting research,
but the other thing
that we have learned
and this goes back to
Shishir your question.
Is it the right thing to learn
a classifier that works
across all backgrounds,
that works across all locations,
and works across
all radar technologies?
We're coming to the point
where that's not
the right answer.
So, we'll have to specialize
the sensor based on its type,
based on its location and some of
this is going to involve
online learning.
So, of course we need
a basis by which sensors can
share their model drift
with the cloud,
and the cloud can come up
with new general models for
everyone or more interestingly
you can do federated learning.
So, what we're running
into a cases while
every sensor is estimating
its own background,
it needs a basis for
being able to relearn on
its model and that can be
done locally and/or
assisted by the cloud.
So, what are
the patterns for that.
So those I think are going to
be very interesting
for limited signals.
So, with that I'll be
happy to take questions.
>> So, what sessions
are thinking of like
the online sessions?
>> Now, actually
sonic. So, yesterday
I spoke about this Sounds
of New York City project,
which I didn't have
time to explain today,
but the situation there
is you're placing sensors
in a very different
parts of the city.
So, some can be an urban canyons,
some can be in city parks,
some can be in
housing areas which
are a mixture of trees
and low buildings.
So, in all of these the
propagation characteristics
will be quite different.
It turns out we do
have information about
these different parts of
the city which can be used to
model how sound will propagate.
So, we have folks on
the data analytic side and
the visualization side
who can tell us,
what we think propagation
characteristics would be.
So, that can be given as
input to your cloud learner,
but the other question
that we can ask is.
How can a censor at
a given location notice that
things have changed enough,
enough foliage has changed,
that my model is no longer
working and become
a basis for triggering?
Or can a sensor benefit
from sharing
it's, what's the right word?
Let's call it Mode.
I hesitate to use
context in this case.
So, we could have
our classification outputs be
done for different modes and can
a sensor provide its mode to
its neighbors as a way of
informing them which might be
the relevant classifier to use?
So, we're basically exploring
a number of options
for handling the drift of
the model of a local sensor,
and one thing that I'm
trying to do is to
provide the plumping to
support that learning.
So, we're reserving
enough energy budget
for sharing data snippets,
which are indicative
that my model seemed
to have low confidence
in assessing this
particular data item,
so how does this inform
the learning of
the regional or global model.
>> But maybe you can do
the online learning sessions,
maybe collect data
for a day or 7 days.
>> Yes.
>> Then learn
a specific model for that.
>> It's possible,
like I mentioned
we have 30 years of data,
so we have data from let's say
50 to 100 locations which
are telling us over
two years how the sound
characteristics changed.
So, assuming that that data gets
labelled and that
labelling is trustworthy,
perhaps that can be done.
Now, how predictive that is
of next year or next spring,
I don't know and that
takes me down this road
of actually just being able to
recognize what mode I mean.
If I can recognize
what mode I'm in,
I can see which classifier
to bring in from
a library of classifies, yes.
>> So, with regard to
changing environment models,
since we are a working
in the RF modelling,
can we use the same technology
for child estimations
that is used
by several others or?
>> Okay, so I'm still trying
to parse your question.
So, perhaps I can talk
about the difference
between Cellular Modelling
and Low-Power sensor,
Low-Power RF Modelling in
as a way of starting
the conversation.
So, very good planning
tools exist for how
cellular characteristics
would be across
the region and they can
tolerate topography quite well,
and it's probably because
they're in a
different SNR regime.
When we tried to use
the similar planning ideas for
deploying our relays
in South Africa,
it turned out that we were
quite bad in estimating
what would work.
So, let me just illustrate that.
So in a Low-power Regime
where you can very quickly go
from constructive to
destructive interference,
moving a radar by
a three or four feet,
actually half a wavelength,
can take you from
constructive to destructive.
But what we found was
that I had to search in
that region to find a spot
where I could deploy my radar.
So, one would have predicted
that going down a hill,
with this medium amount of
vegetation should have given
you 300 meters of range,
but that was not enough
and you had to do
the search which was extremely
painful when you're
climbing trees.
So, as I don't know
how easy it is,
in this low-power regime
to do what you're saying.
Yes.
>> How easy is it for you to
be able to do a camouflage.
>> Well you know for years
I had my boys trying to
behave like dogs and we
were collecting data,
it is not really easy.
So, I'm going to sort of
distort your question.
The question is how would
you fall this radar?
What are the ways of fooling it?
So, one way of fooling it
is to actually move
extremely slowly.
So when you look at
special operations people,
they can sometimes move a meter
an hour when they are crossing
very sensitive borders.
This thing is sensitive up to
2.6 centimeters per second,
but a meter an hour is much
slower than 2.6 centimeters,
so your obscured.
The other thing you can do
is to be extremely fast.
So, the way the filters
on the radar are set,
you can pick up this 2.6 meters a
second and really about
five meters a second.
But it's possible to run
faster than five meters a
second as a way of avoiding this.
We are banking on the fact
that this poacher
is going through this
densely wooded forest scene,
through these narrow trails.
It's actually coming
into this hidden way
and will get picked up.
But if you're doing
the same thing with cars,
this probably will not work.
Yes.
>> [inaudible] ?
>> Yes. It has not
affected us significantly.
So what I'm reporting are cases
where we've deployed
sensors far too close,
where we see a little bit of
observation of a target even
before it enters the scene.
That observation is
not very predictable.
So sometimes, it looks
like a clear target,
sometimes it doesn't look
like a clear target.
So, what I'm saying
is that this is
not a major problem for us in
practice and it's
a manageable problem
in part because we
program things.
As it is, it's
a very low probability that
the periodic pulses will
line up and we are also
throwing in randomness.
Randomness is good because it
makes your radars healthy.
So, it's harder to see
the pulse pattern.
You need a higher
order detector to know
the presence of the
radar. So, yes.
For us, it hasn't
been a major problem,
but we are seeing instances
of this in our training data.
The question is, how
much is it affecting
our training data
is what we are trying
to establish right now?
So, my interest is
I'm seeing if I
can classify it and prune it,
so that I'm only learning from
clean data at the moment.
Yes. [inaudible]
>> Okay. Good question. So, I
think the biggest source of
false alarms has not
been environmental,
it's been radar design issues.
So, if you've got a radar,
which has got
unusually high noise,
and we haven't gotten
the thresholds right for that,
that's radar false positives
tend to occur for us.
But, yes, maybe I should
give another example.
So, the World Wildlife Fund
tested our system,
which was doing a human
versus a catalog classifier,
and it took it onto a horse farm,
and they tested it with horses.
They said, "Yes. I'm
seeing humans all the
time with horses and
your system doesn't work."
So that, I don't
know how to parse.
The system wasn't designed to
discriminate horses as horses.
So, that has caused
some confusion.
So, if we're deploying this in
an environment
where we've trained
for cattle and goats
on one side and humans and
dogs on the other side,
and all of a sudden,
this Writer starts showing up.
We don't know what's
going to happen.
So, that can be viewed as a
false positive in the system.
So, that operator issue
we have today.
Yes. [inaudible]
>> Okay. This is not
a ranging radar.
So, what it lets you do is
to look at the relative distance
not the absolute distance.
Now, if you could do
very coarse localization
because, for example,
in partner the way
it was set up was we
knew there was this trail
coming in close to a village,
which meant a certain distance,
so you are actually putting
sensors along the trail.
So, in that setting, you
already know where
the nodes are located,
and you're within a few meters
of that, and that is sufficient.
But more importantly, you've got
actually multiple
sensors observing,
so you can be more
exact if need be.
Conversely, there's
a lot of research on
very accurate localization
with ultra-wideband radar.
There's a lot of literature
on that if you're interested.
One of my students, [inaudible]
has written some papers on that.
>> [inaudible]
>> Yes. You certainly can and it
costs a lot of power GPS
will take you.
>> GPS [inaudible]
>> Yes. Triangulation is
certainly the way you
handle localization.
The question is, how do you
get your range estimates?
So, you can go to
a ranging radar.
One reason being
introduced the FPGA was so
that we could create
very narrow range gates.
So right now, the way
the radar works is
roughly one and a
half meters from
the radar to about 12-13 meters,
is everything there is
treated as one response,
but you can create range gates,
which are about a meter long.
So, now, you can create
12 such range gates and you can
sweep the radar to each of them.
Then, you can localize
within that distance,
but it's about a half a
meter error rate on average,
whereas what folks
in localization
are trying to do to get
substantive meter and
localization accuracy.
So, that's a slightly richer.
That's a harder problem.
>> [inaudible]
>> This is centered
at 5.8 gigahertz.
It's a medium bandwidth.
So, it's about
a 100 megahertz bandwidth.
It's not an ultra-wideband radar,
but it's still got
rich information.
>> [inaudible]
>> That's a good
question. We have
significant experience with that.
So, we co-exist with Wi-Fi
and Bluetooth without
being affected.
Yup.
Okay. Very good. Thanks a lot.